Era como una simbiosis de arte y vida.
Y creo que no es casual
que el zoótropo se traduce como "rueda de la vida".
(Música)
Pero la película y el video aplanan la escultura,
así que traté de imaginar
un modo en que la escultura animada pudiese experimentarse como tal,
y también como una escultura animada de sumersión completa.
Ahí fue cuando se me ocurrió la idea del túnel zoótropo.
Lo atraviesas con una luz estroboscópica
y adonde apuntas la luz,
la animación cobra vida.
Planeo terminar este proyecto en los próximos 30 o 40 años.
(Risas)
Pero sí construí un prototipo de media escala.
Está cubierto de velcro,
y puedo recostarme dentro, sobre este puente,
pegar secuencias animadas en las paredes,
y probar cómo funciona.
La gente decía que les recordaba a una resonancia magnética.
Y esa conexión médica me resonaba
porque a los 14 años
me diagnosticaron una enfermedad retinal degenerativa
que, de a poco, me quitaba la visión,
y nunca antes había respondido a ello en mi trabajo.
Así que lo hice en esta pieza denominada "Implant".
Es un aparato médico imaginario, súper amplificado
que se coloca alrededor del nervio óptico.
Y el público, de algún modo, se hace miniatura para experimentarlo.
Luz estroboscópica en mano,
pueden explorar la escultura
y descubrir miles de robots de tamaño de células
trabajando arduamente, que saltan dentro y fuera del nervio óptico,
que envían a la retina
para repararla.
Es mi cura de fantasía de ciencia ficción a mi propia enfermedad incurable.
(Zumbidos de máquinas)
En el mundo real de la terapia de genes y su investigación,
se administran genes sanos a células enfermas usando virus.
Hay mucha esperanza de colores y peluche en esto,
y también hay una idea amenazante y terrorífica
de que los virus pueden convertirse en especies invasivas en el cuerpo.
La pérdida de la visión me ayudó a alejarme de las cosas
que me desconectan del mundo.
En vez de estar encerrado en un automóvil,
ando en bicicleta,
tomo autobuses y trenes
y camino mucho.
En vez de priorizar el proceso visual intensivo en el estudio
también estoy afuera mucho más
y uso más mis sentidos.
Este paisaje está a unas horas al este de San Diego, California.
Mi hermano vive por allí.
Juntos fuimos a acampar allí durante cuatro días.
Tomé mi cámara
y caminé entre los cañones.
E intenté imaginar y descubrir
qué tipo de movimiento podría haber
en este lugar tan quieto y privado de movimiento.
Creo que es el lugar más quieto al que he ido.
Me di cuenta de que era mi propio movimiento en el paisaje
el que creaba la animación.
Era el movimiento del cambio de perspectiva.
Así que creé esta pieza, "Mud Caves" con esas fotografías.
Es una pieza de impresiones en muchas capas
y pueden pensarla como un zoótropo en el llano.
Es mi panorama del paisaje del oeste.
Junto a la pieza impresa hay un monitor de video
que muestra la animación escondida en la obra de arte.
Creo que una de las mejores partes de este proyecto para mí
fue que pude pasar mucho tiempo con mi hermano,
que vive a 4000 km de mí.
Nos sentamos en este paisaje que parece eterno,
esculpido por el agua durante millones de años,
y hablamos.
Hablamos de cómo crecen nuestros hijos
y del ritmo lento de nuestros padres,
y de papá que sufre de leucemia, pérdida de memoria e infección.
Y se me ocurrió que, como individuos,
somos finitos,
pero como familia,
somos un ciclo en movimiento...
una especie de rueda de la vida.
Quiero dejarlos con un tributo a uno de mis mentores.
Ella me recuerda que la presencia física es importante
y que el juego no es un lujo,
sino una necesidad.
Ella es Pixie,
la perra de nuestra familia.
Le encanta saltar.
(Perro ladrando)
(Perro ladrando y ruido de resorte)
Y este es un nuevo tipo de zoótropo
que desarrollé en el Imaging Research Center
en UMBC, en Baltimore.
Lo llamo "zoótropo de tiempo real".
(Perro ladrando)
(Perro ladrando y ruido de resorte)
Gracias.
(Aplausos)